Because as B.B. King put it,...
..."The beautiful thing about learning is that nobody can take that away from you."
And learning is really in the broadest sense what I really want to talk about today,...
...because your education, of course, isn't ending here.
In many ways, it's only just begun.
The world has so many lessons to teach you.
I consider the world, this Earth to be like a school and our life the classrooms.
And sometimes here in this "Planet Earth School", the lessons often come dressed up...
...as detours or roadblocks and sometimes as full-blown crises.
And the secret I've learned to getting ahead is being open to the lessons.
Lessons from the grandest universe of all, that is the universe itself.
It's being able to walk through life eager and open to self-improvement...
...and that which is going to best help you evolve,...
...'cause that's really why we're here, to evolve as human beings.
So, to grow into being more of ourselves,...
...always moving to the next level of understanding,...
...the next level of compassion and growth.
I think one of the greatest compliments I've ever received,...
...I interviewed with a reporter when I was first starting out in Chicago...
...and then many years later, I saw the same reporter, and she said to me,...
..."You know what? You really haven't changed. You've just become more of yourself."
And that is really what we're all trying to do, become more of ourselves.
And I believe that there's a lesson in almost everything that you do, and every experience,...
...and getting the lesson is how you move forward.
It's how you enrich your spirit.
And trust me, I know that inner wisdom is more precious than wealth.
The more you spend it, the more you gain.